la marche à blind du Réseau Express
métropolitain LEM ça a commencé ce matin
c'est l'ultime étape avant la mise en
service du train léger entre Montréal et
Brossard mais le développement des
quartiers autour des stations du remu
lui et entamée depuis longtemps on fait
le point ce soir avec Dory nasserde et
les maires de Brossard bonsoir madame
Assane bonsoir alors si on parle du REM
là je vais pas faire de mauvais jeux de
mots mais après plusieurs repas le train
est enfin en marche et là à quel point
c'est fondamental pour vous que ça se
passe bien que ça aille de l'avant et
qu'on offre le service avant la rentrée
c'est important vous l'aviez bien dit la
rentrée scolaire c'est le moment le plus
stressant pour les étudiants pour les
parents et c'est là qu'on sent ce qui
est le plus de congestions automobile je
pense que c'est à ce moment-là que le
rhum va pouvoir faire ses preuves auprès
des utilisateurs donc il faut faudrait
absolument que ça soit 20 ou début
septembre et créer des habitudes aussi
je pense que c'est l'objectif de peu
près tous les parties dans ce dossier là
donc avant même que ce soit en service
ça ça économique ce réseau express métro
Martin pour les villes pour la vôtre en
particulier avec énormément de
développement immobilier vous avez le
projet entre autres de Devil solar uni
quartier c'est gros ça est-ce que est-ce
que vous êtes satisfaite de la façon
dont ça avance jusqu'à maintenant ça
avance bien nous sommes à 50 % de
construction du projet un projet solaire
unicquartier on prévoit environ 6000
unités avec c'est sûr que pour nous à la
Ville de Brossard ça démontre l'intérêt
les fervescence économiques qu'on a et
c'est étroitement bien sûr lié à
l'arrivée du rêve oui absolument parce
que ce qu'on comprend c'est que c'est un
quartier à haute densité collée sur la
station
une petite ville en soi là c'est ça et
c'est un concept que vous souhaitez
répéter ça madame Assane oui absolument
mais de façon moduler dans le fond nous
nous sommes en réflexion pour voir
jusqu'où on veut aller à la Ville de
Brossard donc on a pris charge un peu
contrôle du développement parce que
sinon ça allait être réparti un peu
partout puis on veut concentrer nos
efforts autour manifestations reine puis
notre centre-ville ce sera autour du
stationnement du stationnement
parce que là le quartier dont on parle
devine trop solar c'est près de la
station du quartier pour pré-près du
quartier du 30 là pour ceux qui
connaissent le coin la station Panama
vous préparez activement l'aménagement
et on appelle le même ça un nouveau
centre-ville pour Brossard quel est le
projet exactement exacte pour nous ça va
être l'opportunité de créer un milieu de
vie qui va répondre aux attentes de la
population existante ainsi que les
futures résidents qui vont s'y installer
l'idéal pour nous c'est de créer un
milieu de vie ou dans 15 minutes qui ont
accès à tout ce qui ont besoin que ce
soit municipal ou non en matière de
santé en matière d'éducation donc ça va
être vraiment une belle opportunité pour
faire quelque chose d'un projet
environnemental qui encourage la
mobilité qui est pas conçu autour de
l'automobile mais qui peut être accédé
en voiture ça va être vraiment excellent
et là vous avez parlé d'éducation ça
c'est intéressant parce que dans les
premiers projets qui ont été développés
autour des stations du REM ce que je
crois comprendre c'est que ça répondait
peut-être pas à tous les besoins en
matière d'éducation entre autres on vous
a entendu le déplorer le fait que en
fait que vous auriez aimé voir un peu
plus d'espace vert avoir des milieux
d'enseignements est-ce que c'est un
élément qui va être une priorité pour
les prochains projets la densité c'est
important mais il faut créer des
environnements ou les gens puissent y
rester à partir du début de leur cycle
de vie jusqu'à la fin et donc
l'éducation en est important les espaces
verts très très importants pour le
bien-être des citoyen donc à chaque fois
qu'on développe un tas d'un transit on
apprend on évolue c'est ça Brossard on
est habitué à gérer la croissance puis à
chaque fois ça nous permet de se
dépasser dans là vous me parlez de
croissance madame Assad si les
intentions de tous les promoteurs qui
s'intéressent à Brossard se concrétise
la population de votre ville pourrait
doubler est-ce que c'est c'est réaliste
c'est pas y aller d'ailleurs selon nos
projections si on n'avait pas mis en
place notre règlement de contrôle
interimaire le temps qu'on fasse la
réflexion en forme de moratoire qui ne
concerne pas nécessairement le
centre-ville de la Ville de Brossard
mais on aurait pu monter jusqu'à 57000
unités mais le Conseil veut pas ça moi
je veux pas ça on veut vraiment créer
une environnement où tout le monde a sa
place puis des milieux de vie vivables
donc pour nous ça va être dans les
environs de 30 mille unités mais ça
entraîne quand même plusieurs défis
c'est ce que les infrastructures sont
capables de soutenir cette croissance de
population le 30 000 oui c'est
d'ailleurs une des raisons pour nous
qu'on sait qu'on n'a pas l'intention de
le dépasser ça se peut que ce soit un
peu moins l'idée c'est de juste définir
c'est quoi le type de projet qu'on veut
avoir et de s'assurer de prendre
contrôle du développement vous avez
instauré une redevance sur les nouvelles
constructions madame Assane sauf pour le
logement abordable on le précise c'est à
peu près 3500 dollars qui s'ajoutent au
prix de toutes les nouvelles unités
pourquoi pour nous qui est une façon de
démontrer à la population existante que
oui il y a une croissance oui il y a du
développement mais ça va bénéficier à
eux aussi il faut pas qu'il soit dans un
cycle de gestion du changement où ils
ont juste les inconvénients du
changement pour nous le 3500 unités
excusez moi 3500 dollars va permettre de
créer un fond qui va s'appliquer à des
installations éducatives à nous des
nouveaux infrastructures municipales ça
va être vraiment pour bonifier la
qualité de vie déjà donc pour répondre
aux besoins futurs est-ce que tout ça a
un impact pour les résidents actuels la
valeur foncière par exemple est-ce qu'on
peut s'attendre à ce que ça grimpe parce
que ça vient avec des hausses de taxes
est-ce que c'est sur votre radar on
souhaite aussi
le marché immobilier escalier puis on
voit que la valeur d'une maison moyenne
monte doucement mais ce que je dis à la
aux citoyens c'est acheter abrassant
vous allez voir ça va valoir le coup ça
va juste monter bon en fait tout le
monde attend là la réelle mise en
service et la date d'ouverture le
premier trajet officiellement avait
passager de ce réseau express
métropolitain je suis certaine que vous
serez au premier loge madame Massad
merci beaucoup d'être passé merci
beaucoup pour l'invitation pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]